every two years one million Japanese
disappear China's population will halve
by the end of the century the median age
in Italy has reached 48. all around the
world birth rates are crashing is
Humanity dying out what's going on and
how bad is it
[Music]
for hundreds of thousands of years the
human population barely grew at all
haunted by disease famine and War until
the Industrial Revolution exponential
progress led to exponential growth
pushing our numbers to 6 billion in the
year 1999 and 8 billion just 24 years
later
and our numbers will continue to rise
for at least another 60 years but this
growth obscures something people kind of
stopped having babies
for a stable population every couple
needs to have two children on average if
the number is higher it grows if lower
it shrinks if it's well below it shrinks
a lot and quickly like in South Korea
one of the hottest exporters of Pop
Culture its fertility rate layer 0.8
children per woman in 2022 the lowest in
the world this means 100 South Koreans
of childbearing age today will have 40
kids who then will have 16 kids who then
will have sex
if nothing changes then within 100 years
there will be 94 fewer young people and
South Korea will see a population
implosion that is if things stay the
same we have yet to see if there's a
bottom to fertility rates although
looking at the bigger picture and
absolute numbers this population will
not shrink that much it simply returns
to the level it once was in 1950 there
were 20 million South Koreans in 2023
there are 52 million and by 2 100 there
will be 24 million again but the issue
is not that there will be fewer South
Koreans the issue is the composition of
the population in 1950 the median age
was 18. in 2023 it's 45. in 2100 it will
be 59. a country of seniors and South
Korea is far from alone China may be
seeing the steepest population reversal
in history Unstoppable at this point
rapid industrialization urbanization and
Rising incomes meant that the Chinese
started to prefer smaller families that
plus the introduction of the one child
policy which aims to slow population
growth means that China has had a low
fertility rate for decades with a
fertility rate of 1.16 births per woman
within four generations 100 young
Chinese will turn into 20. China's
fertility rates are now one of the
lowest in East Asia lower than even
Japan's
in comparison Europe's depopulation is
much slower despite low fertility since
unlike Asia Most states have had a
steady flow of immigrants
the impact is complex as a good chunk of
immigrants come from other low fertility
rate areas the number of immigrant women
who do have a lot of children is not yet
high enough to make a big dent and
fertility rates of immigrants tend to
adjust to the native population within
two to three generations in Eastern
Europe the decline has sped up even more
because many young people have emigrated
to Stronger economies like Germany whose
median age is one of the highest in the
world at 46.
Latin America fell below replacement in
2015. in the U.S immigration is the only
thing keeping the population growing
substantially there are still places
where fertility rates have not Fallen
below replacement yet in much of the
Middle East North and sub-Saharan Africa
fertility is still high which creates
the same concerns about overpopulation
as when Asia grew very quickly in the
1950s but that turned out to be
unfounded
but recently the UN has reduced its
forecast for Africa's population
drastically for Nigeria estimates were
lowered from 733 million to 546 Million
by 2100. similar Trends are being noted
across the continent as Africa develops
fertility rates are shrinking much
faster than anticipated it's becoming
more likely that East Asia's story will
repeat itself by the end of the century
most places in Africa may be below
replacement too
so declining birth rates and aging
populations have become a general Trend
all over the world why is all of this a
big deal
demographics and poverty for a
functioning Society you need enough
people in the prime of their lives young
and middle-aged people do most of the
work in any economic system working age
people create a society's wealth in
retirement you stop contributing as much
to the economy but the majority of
health care costs are generated by
seniors the way the world worked in the
past was that a lot of younger people
took care of a few older people imagine
a society where most people are older
than 60. the financial burden for the
young will be immense unsustainable even
for the richest countries even in the
best case this will mean people having
to work way longer exploding health care
costs and poverty while states with
shrinking incomes struggle to keep up
with Rising costs technology might
soften the blow but can't compensate
entirely we can see this happening
already 11 out of 31 provinces in China
are running deficits for their Pension
funds they got old before they got rich
and now they can't read catch up anymore
China's working age population is
predicted to fall by 20 or 200 million
people by 2050 as much as today's entire
working age population of the US
infrastructure collapse is an almost
Universal constant of population decline
because infrastructure works at scale
and doesn't get cheaper to operate if
it's used by fewer people if a
population declines be it because of
urbanization or the loss of industry and
employment once people and their income
disappear the resource is necessary to
sustain infrastructure disappear too you
can see it in many depopulated towns and
cities in East Germany that suffered
sharp population decline after German
reunification or look at Japan you can
tour the countryside to see dying towns
wait if there are a few people won't
life get cheaper and better and there'll
be more resources to go around well no
population decline doesn't lead to
prosperity it's people's ideas and work
that create our prosperity not the mere
availability of resources another danger
for aging societies is that elected
governments could decide to mostly
represent the interests and fears of
their elderly populations potentially
leading to short-term thinking and a
preference for conserving wealth over
Innovation that's not a society that can
handle issues like climate change which
need massive investment and fresh ideas
something the world is already having a
hard time with
many people think that having fewer
humans on Earth is actually a good thing
because our societies are too
unsustainable we're using up too many
resources and because of climate change
the problem is that even if you want
fewer humans this process is very likely
too slow to have a positive impact on
the environment
the world population is going to grow
for at least 60 more years before it may
shrink Again by then we have to solve
climate change likewise any other upside
to lower population might have will most
likely not materialize themselves this
century
so just like import people
the easiest solution seems to be
immigration but fertility of immigrants
adjusts to local levels within three
generations so you need a constant
influx of new migrants which is not
sustainable long term as birth rates are
dropping everywhere the only way would
be to keep poor countries poor so that
the young and motivated migrate to
developed countries looking for
opportunity and a better life kind of an
immoral thing to Wish For by the end of
the century Africa will have the highest
number of young people in the world and
so African migrants might become the
world's most sought after immigrants
with the elderly Nations fighting hard
for every person willing to make the
move
immigration can also create societal or
cultural tensions which is a universal
phenomenon in all cultures especially
when cultures with very different sets
of values meet often leading to a
backlash that slows immigration down
again it's easy to be frustrated at this
but ignoring this will only divide
societies Empower demagogues and
increase xenophobia
economically immigration is largely
beneficial for societies even if this
seems counter-intuitive to many people
especially countries like the US an
immigrant Nation built on the idea of
personal freedom and opportunity through
hard work will benefit the most
countries like this will have a clear
Advantage this Century especially if
they can attract the world's brightest
and most ambitious
conclusion and our opinion
this topic is way too big affects
societies as diverse as literally all of
humanity so please take this part with a
gigantic grain of salt obviously we're
looking at this from our central
European perspective one way to look at
falling birth rates is as a side effect
of the world being less bad than it was
especially women are Freer more educated
and wealthier than in the past
but it turns out that if societies are
better off individuals often decide to
have fewer kids interestingly there's a
gap between how many kids people want
and how many they're having the mean
number of kids women in Europe want is
around 2.3 much more than they're
actually having while we gained a lot of
freedoms in the last century across
continents and economic systems that
came at a cost the tight-knit
communities and family structures that
were part of our nature where kids could
be brought up by a village today young
parents have to deal with different
challenges and societal expectations
women are kind of ground down between
the wish and expectation to have a
family and a career being pressured to
do both but not compromise either men
are sharing parental duties more equally
than they used to but are often still
expected to be the provider and it's
sadly truth that usually at least one
parent's career is held back in many
developed countries the gender pay Gap
is chiefly a pay gap between mothers and
everyone else but it's not just outside
pressure our culture of individualism
probably plays a role too we have only
one life to explore be free travel have
fun accomplish something and try to be
happy so people commit to Partners later
in life and often decide against big
families or any at all and that's fair
nobody owes their country babies
so far no country has successfully
managed to increase birth rate
significantly so as of now we don't
really know what works but here are a
few options to at least make the lives
of parents much easier free and abundant
access to child care Financial benefits
for parents more and cheaper housing
Parenthood has to stop being a career
obstacle and our culture needs to become
more positive towards families and
that's something we can all work on the
next time you sit next to a crying baby
don't be a jerk about it kids are hard
in the end Humanity will not die out
because we're having fewer babies the
age and composition of our societies
changes quickly and we need to deal with
that sooner rather than later but in the
end of all the incredibly hard
challenges we've faced before why would
this be the one we can't solve
getting to the bottom of the population
crash starts with analyzing and
interpreting massive amounts of data and
if you're looking for a free way to
start building your data skills which
are more essential than ever these days
we recommend brilliant.org brilliant's
latest course predicting with
probability will teach you everything
you need to get started in data science
no coding required you'll analyze vast
data sets compare distributions and
master fundamental concepts that are key
to some of the most in-demand careers in
today's world Beyond data brilliant is
the best way to master key Concepts in
everything from maths and science to
computer science and programming just
set your goal and Brilliant designs the
perfect path and equips you with the
right tools to reach it they have
thousands of lessons to explore and each
one is interactive like a one-on-one
version of a kotskazard video we've
actually designed a whole series of
lessons in collaboration with our
friends at brilliant that cover the
topics from our most popular videos from
rabies and mammalian metabolism to
climate science and supernovas and you
can try them and many more for free
today to get Hands-On with quotes Arc
lessons and explore everything brilliant
has to offer you can start your free
30-day trial by signing up at
brilliant.org nutshell there's even an
extra perk for kotzuk viewers the first
200 people to use the link get 20 off an
annual membership once their trial ends
foreign
[Music]